bienvenidos a un nuevo programa de la
entrevista con france 24 desde nueva
york hoy nos acompaña el vicepresidente
del salvador el señor félix ulloa que
visita estos días la ciudad en el marco
de la reunión de alto nivel de las
naciones unidas para discutir como los
países están trabajando en implementar
las medidas para conseguir esa agenda
del 2030 del desarrollo sostenible
muchas gracias por acompañarnos señor yo
a un placer claro es un gran gusto estar
contigo y con toda la audiencia de
france 24 aprovechando su visita en este
país a mí me gustaría hablar sobre la
actualidad del suyo y me gustaría
comenzar precisamente con unas
declaraciones de eeuu que decía que
ustedes hicieron un pacto con las
pandillas para bajar la tasa de
homicidios pero ese pacto no ha
funcionado al parecer qué es lo que ha
ido mal bueno pues creo que se
equivocaron de datta o de época porque
quienes hicieron pacto con las pandillas
fueron los dos gobiernos anteriores
de arena y el gobierno del fmln eso está
plenamente documentado hay vídeos y
audios con los cuales se demostraban
esos pactos en más hubo uno que fue
bendecido por la oea que se hizo durante
el gobierno del presidente funes cuando
el entonces secretario general el señor
insulza llegó al salvador para no solo
dar su aval a ese pacto sino que también
decir pues que era un modelo de solución
de esos conflictos que vivimos en esa
época y como justifica entonces que
durante la llegada del señor
los homicidios bajarán y de repente
volvieran a subir hay quien dice que fue
porque seis acuerdos con las pandillas
se rompieron y fue como una reacción en
cadena quienes dice que eso no conocen
el salvador ni conocen la gestión de
este gobierno los homicidios bajaron y
toda la acción de las pandillas porque
el día 19 20 de junio del año 2019
apenas tres semanas de haber llegado al
gobierno se implementó el plan con thor
territorial es un plan de siete etapas
que la primera fue la intervención en
los territorios en las comunidades
controladas por las pandillas en las
pandillas controlaban más de un tercio
del territorio nacional tenían
secuestradas a las comunidades y de
rodillas al estado con el plan control
territorial en la primera fase se tomó
el control de los territorios luego
entró la intervención del estado con los
servicios públicos e íbamos a la tercera
etapa que era el equipamiento de la
fuerza del orden cuando la asamblea
legislativa controlada por esos dos
partidos arena y el fmln negaron la
ratificación de un préstamo del banco
centroamericano de integración económica
de 109 millones para comprar todos los
equipos y todas las municiones el
armamento los vehículos los beckham y de
los aparatos para la intercomunicación
que necesitaban la fuerza del orden
cuando se dio el repunte de las
pandillas fue porque en el salvador
hemos estado estando a la
vanguardia de muchas medidas de carácter
económico que han posicionado al país
como líder a nivel mundial como el caso
de él cuando se llegaba la presencia de
inversionistas de la talla de ricardo
salinas pliego de mexico y otros
inversionistas norteamericanos las
plantillas de costaron la oportunidad
apoyados por los poderes fácticos y
políticos del pasado que quedaron
relegados en las últimas elecciones para
lanzar una ofensiva y desacreditar la
imagen del gobierno ahí fue donde ese
decreto del estado de excepción como una
reacción a esta acción criminal que
durante un fin de semana el luto a más
de 80 familias salvadoreñas tú no puedes
creer que eso es producto de que haya un
pacto no hubiera habido un pacto las
mismas pandillas hubieran salido a
denunciarlo y decir de qué porque no se
había cumplido el plan del gobierno las
habas ofesiva pero lo que ha pasado y lo
que tenemos como resultado a tres meses
y medio de haber implementado de ese
estado de excepciones que hemos
capturado más de 45 mil miembros de
pandillas que están en prisión que han
sido puestos a la orden de los jueces y
de los cuales el 80% ya se decretó la
detención provisional se han decomisado
millones de dólares vehículos armas en
fin toda una batalla una guerra como lo
ha llamado el presidente bucl es una
guerra contra las pandillas que no se
explicaría si hubiese habido un pacto o
una alianza como acuerdo con ellos
porque estarían reclamando justamente
que se cumpliera ese pacto pero lo que
están haciendo y huyendo del país
escondiéndose en las comunidades y la
misma población no está denunciando y
por eso el éxito toda esta campaña de
capturas que tenemos hasta la fecha pues
te habla de muchas detenciones pero en
esas detenciones también se está
incluyendo gente con que
de hecho ha habido una denuncia de la
violación de derechos humanos sin país
entonces 45 mil personas que no sabemos
realmente si pertenecen a estas
pandillas o si si sabemos cuántas porque
ya los jueces establecieron y hasta la
fecha tenemos el informe del procurador
de la agencia de los derechos humanos
que tiene dos mil 673 denuncias cuando
se cumplieron los tres meses del estado
de excepción
a menos de un 5% de todas las personas
capturadas lo cual te indica que la
operación ha tenido un éxito en un 95
por ciento que exista al final esos
jueces que dan garantías de un proceso
justo son precisamente los que su
gobierno ha puesto no el gobierno no
pone jueces en el salvador hay una
separación de poderes y los jueces la
nombra el órgano judicial lo que tenemos
ahora son jueces que se sienten
respaldados el gobierno para poder
dictaminar las detenciones que se están
dando detenciones provisionales mientras
llegan a los juicios y no tienen el
temor que tenían antes y que por eso
cuando la policía ha capturado a un
grupo de pandilleros los jueces los
ponían en libertad que habían amenazas
había una serie de presiones de
extorsiones de hecho un periodista
español que se dice salvadoreño roberto
valencia en madrid confesó que él había
llevado a un mensaje de un jefe de una
de las pandillas a una jueza qué tipo de
mensajes le puede enviar un jefe de
pandilla a una jueza es decir porque
también había vasos comunicantes entre
ciertos sectores de algunos medios como
donde trabaje este señor roberto
valencia y otros que han hecho de la
industria de la de las pandillas todo un
modus vivendi con reportajes con libros
porque tienen esas conexiones un vaso
comunicante y son ellos los que han
salido a la opinión pública y sobre todo
a los medios internacionales con este
cuento de que hay unas detenciones
masivas arbitrarias y por supuesto toda
obra humana como sabemos perfectible y
nadie dice que no se han cometido
errores y yo no tengo duda que esas dos
mil 673 denuncias que hay en la
procuraduría puede haber mucha gente que
estaba en el momento equivocado en el
lugar equivocado y fue capturada pero
así de esa misma manera están saliendo
por los jueces cuando se llega a
comprobar que no tenía ninguna relación
con las pandillas que son trabajadores
que iban pasando o tenían estaban en el
lugar equivocado cuando hubo una captura
masiva pues están siendo puestos en
libertad
y algunos y otros lo que le decimos a
sus familiares bueno los que se quedan
es porque hay alguna evidencia que es
otra de las bondades que ha permitido el
estado de excepción que es extender el
periodo de la detención administrativa
porque anteriormente y puede ser que
muchos jueces no tenían la evidencia
para dejar detenidos a los criminales y
los que ponían en libertad porque según
la ley penal y según la constitución
nadie puede ser detenido por más de 72
horas
entonces en 72 horas no se lograban las
evidencias y nos ponían libertad ahora
con el régimen de excepción que tiene
como una de las consecuencias del
extender el periodo de la detención
administrativa a 15 días hay la
suficiente
posibilidad de la fiscalía de presentar
evidencias y de ahí que más del 80% de
los capturados que pasan a la orden de
los jueces están quedando ya bajo la
detención de judicial dentro del sistema
penitenciario por orden de juez no
porque lo capturó la policía o lo metió
la fiscalía sino ya bajo el mecanismo
del sistema judicial y hasta cuándo
durará este estado de excepción o sea
cuál es meta ya sea en tiempo en número
de detenciones en objetivos mira lo que
ha dicho porque el estado decepción sólo
lo puede prorrogar la asamblea
legislativa ya no es el gobierno no es
el judicial es el órgano legislativo el
que decide si lo extiende o no mientras
subsistan las condiciones que lo generan
eso se va a mantener definido no
indefinido hasta que subsistan porque el
salvador lo que vivimos la época de la
guerra si sabemos que el estado de
excepción no duró ni seis meses en y un
año de varios años lo que tiene que
hacerse que cada mes se va prorrogando
yo viví bajo el estado de excepción
durante más de tres cuatro o cinco años
porque cada mes se prorrogaba porque en
esa época del conflicto
el entonces órgano judicial
legislativo consideraba que habían
condiciones para mantener el estado de
excepción y estábamos bajo ese régimen
ahora apenas llevamos pues tres
extensiones y creemos que en poco tiempo
cuando se logre determinar que las
comunidades están libres
este flagelo que la gente que vivía bajo
la extorsión el crimen que se cometía
que íbamos a tener más de dos dígitos
18 20 muertos diarios por la violencia
de las pandillas se libere entonces creo
yo que
serán las condiciones la forma acelerada
en que se lleven a cabo toda esta
limpieza en las comunidades para
liberarlas de este flagelo la que van a
determinar están la relativa decida que
termina ya el estado de excepción ahora
vale la pena decir algo que muchos de
los que no conocen el salvador que
declaran desde washington desde londres
y hacen condenas y emiten comunicados
sin saber lo que pasa ya no saben que el
estado de excepción no está afectando la
vida pública de la ciudadanía
al revés vivían con miedo no están las
pandillas hoy al revés hoy la gente sale
a los parques sale a caminar en las
noches se siente libre algo que no podía
hacer antes y gracias a qué
a excepción porque como digo el
presidente del estado decepción afectar
las zonas donde operan las pandillas
pero tú viste todo antes de la semana
santa todas las festividades religiosas
las procesiones se desarrollaron sin
ningún problema los eventos deportivos
las playas todo la vida si hacia el
salvador ves que es normal donde se está
aplicando las medidas de excepción es en
la zona donde operan estos individuos
que ahora frente a la acción de la
policía se han escapado de las
comunidades y se han ido a las zonas
rurales están viviendo en campamentos y
ahí se está yendo la acción de la
policía nos queda muy poquito tiempo
sobre el bitcoin aquí hay medios que
publican que ha sido el experimento
fallido de buque le parece ser que la
población no estaba preparada para estas
cripto monedas como afectado está la
economía de su país y cuáles son los
planes del gobierno bueno no le afecta
de nada porque no ha habido una
inversión sustancial no se han perdido
cerca de 53 millones de edad no se ha
perdido ni un centavo porque el gobierno
no ha vendido nada o sea que compra un
precio y ahí tiene esos son activos
pero tú pierdes cuando compras a un
precio y vende a un precio menor el
gobierno el salvador compra un precio y
los bienes más las hace poco cuando bajó
a 20.000 el valor el presidente compro
más porque porque la población ahora
está utilizando bueno la población si lo
utiliza no todos los 4 millones que
tuvieron la posibilidad de tener el
chivo wallet pero se están recibiendo y
hay más de 80 millones que se han
enviado solo de las remesas de acá de
eeuu al salvador porque la gente ve que
puede enviar ese dinero sin pagar
condiciones porque un ser se va a seguir
apostando por el bitcoin se va a seguir
con la construcción de la planta
fotovoltaica del consorcio sobre esto es
que eso es decir una cosa está
relacionada con la otra pero no depende
de ella la construcción de toda la
industria de la generación de energía
geotérmica es un proyecto de desarrollo
en novales que va en la línea de
naciones unidas en el objetivo de cuidar
el medio ambiente pero no sólo se trata
de que va a haber
lo que se ha dicho la vid coincide que
va a estar en las faldas del volcán
conchagua que se va a alimentar con esta
energía geotérmica sino que es una
ventana de desarrollo del salvador con
nuevas energías renovables a la cual les
estamos apostando de hecho estamos
presidiendo la agencia internacional de
energía entonces yo creo que hay muchas
lecturas equivocadas desde el país como
esa por ejemplo que se está perdiendo o
que el gobierno ha perdido el primero no
ha perdido un centavo y si tú ves en el
hielo qué es lo que pasa no hay
educación financiera mucha gente que
creyó de que iba a comprar bitcoin hoy y
que lo iba a vender todo en un mes y va
a tener una tasa de rentabilidad no es
para eso de la compra de activos o de
los críticos activos es cuando tú lo ves
en el largo plazo porque la economía
mundial va hacia eso va hacia las
monedas digitales lo que tienes que
hacer tú es tener una reserva y si tiene
un dinero si tú tienes cinco o diez mil
dólares que no lo vas a usar y decide
invertir en cristo' monedas sabes que en
un año en dos años pues a lo mejor no
tienes la recuperación o la tasa de
retorno que tú estabas esperando
pero dentro de 5 o 10 años a lo mejor sí
entonces esto de lo que se trata es de
tener reservas en esta moneda no de
estar en un stock márquez como las
acciones que hoy compras acciones y las
venden mañana y suben y bajan y ese es
el error que ha habido de muchos
críticos que piensan el país compró el
disco ingrid poder comprar también en
otro script o moneda y que luego la
hubiera vender y ganar es decir se
compra para tenerlo como una reserva
estratégica y en el largo plazo vamos a
ver hacia dónde va porque es el mundo el
que va hacia esa era digital y son las
monedas digitales las monedas del futuro
señores gracias por su tiempo
de placer
[Música]
bien